ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen wenn
ihr euch denkt schon wieder ein
flüchtlingsgipfel was da wohl bei
rausgekommen ist dann stellt ihr euch
genau die Frage die wir uns in der
Redaktion heute auch gestellt haben wir
schauen auf die Ergebnisse auf die
Zahlen auf die Probleme die angesprochen
wurden und auch auf mögliche Lösungen
und wir freuen uns sehr wenn ihr
mitdiskutiert wenn ihr mit fragt wie
immer über die Chats oder gerne per Mail
an ZDF heute-live@zdf.de
wir beginnen mit zwei die heute dabei
waren und die zwei sehr sagen wir mal
unterschiedliche Sichtweisen auf die
Ergebnisse dieser Veranstaltung haben
und zwar der Präsident des Deutschen
Landkreistages Reinhard Saga und die
Gastgeberin Innenministerin Nancy Faeser
wir mobilisieren zusätzlichen Wohnraum
und Unterkünfte für geflüchtete wir
schaffen mit einem digitalen
migrations-dashboard für Ländern
Kommunen jederzeit Transparenz über die
aktuelle migrationslage wir sorgen für
mehr Steuerung mehr Ordnung und mehr
Rückführung wir sorgen für Integration
von Anfang an die Länge der Sitzung
dürfen sie nicht so verstehen dass wir
auch entsprechend vier Stunden
hervorragende Ergebnisse produziert
haben das ist leider nicht der Fall
also wir hören das Herr Sager nicht
zufrieden ist und wir haben einen in der
Sendung von dem ich jetzt gespannt bin
zu erfahren wie sein Blick auf die
Ergebnisse dieses Gipfels sind das ist
der Landrat Christian Engelhardt er ist
CDU-Politiker aus dem Kreis Bergstraße
in Hessen und er ist einer der Landräte
die schon vor langer Zeit einen
Brandbrief an den Kanzler geschickt
haben mit der Bitte dass ich etwas
ändern müsste an der Situation der Engel
hat wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
dann haben sie bis heute keine Antwort
auf diesen Brief bekommen und wir sehen
ja auch dass der Kanzler heute an diesem
Treffen nicht teilgenommen hat was sagt
das aus über den Stellenwert des Themas
schönen guten Abend ja der Stellenwert
das Thema ist das ist zumindest die
Sichtweise die wir vor Ort haben in
Berlin
möglicherweise erst jetzt oder noch
nicht recht richtig angekommen es geht
nicht nur darum dass wir Kommunen große
Probleme mit der Unterbringung der
Flüchtlinge haben dass wir darin
tatsächlich eine gesellschaftliche
Herausforderung sehen und der Meinung
sind dass der Kanzler weil es um
internationale Themen geht sich selbst
dieser Sache annehmen müsste sie zu
Chefsache machen müsste und dazu
beitragen dass es tatsächlich Lösungen
gibt und nicht nur Arbeitsgruppen die
gebildet werden
Stichwort Arbeitsgruppen das ist eines
der Ergebnisse die heute beim Gipfel
rausgekommen sind ein anderes ist ein
Dashboard wo man die Verteilung
irgendwie digital auch besser steuern
oder überhaupt überblicken kann da fragt
man sich natürlich seit 2015 warum gibt
es das nicht alles schon was ist denn
ihr Blick auf die Ergebnisse heute
die Ergebnisse sind ernüchternd und auch
ein Stück weit frustrierend weil die
Situation uns hier vor Ort sehr fordert
letztendlich das einzige was geholfen
hätte wären klare Signale dass
kurzfristig deutlich weniger Flüchtlinge
bei uns in den Kommunen ankommen dazu
würde der Bund ja durchaus Instrumente
gehabt und hätte der Bund einfach gesagt
die Flüchtlinge die jetzt neu nach
Deutschland kommen werden zunächst
einmal vom Bund in
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften untergebracht
bis die Asylverfahren ein Stück weit
fortgeschritten sind im Augenblick
kommen sehr viele Menschen zu uns jede
Woche etwa 60 ich kann Ihnen gerne
gleich noch mal erläutern was das die
Faktor vor Ort bedeutet in 60 klingt
nicht so viel aber jeder weitere kommt
bringt uns immer näher ans Limit und ähm
dieses Limit ist
kein wohlfühl-limits dann ist das
absolute Limit dessen was wir hier
leisten können können Sie die Situation
entschuldigung ich habe damals können
Sie die Situation bei sich vor Ort mal
ein bisschen schildern
gerne wir haben im letzten Jahr etwa
4000 Menschen zu uns gekommen der
größere teilweise aus Ukraine etwa
zweieinhalbtausend und die weiteren sind
Menschen aus den sogenannten
trittstaaten davon die größte Gruppe
übrigens Menschen aus der Türkei das war
allerdings vor dem Erdbeben und diese
Menschen müssen wir unterbringen wir
haben Menschen aus Ukraine zum Anfang
recht gut in Wohnungen unterbringen
können weil uns viele Menschen ich hatte
öffentlich dazu aufgerufen Wohnraum zur
Verfügung gestellt haben den wir
anbieten konnten aber auch dieses Modell
war endlich so dass in der Summe in
unserem Kreis
insgesamt auch mehr als 3000 Menschen in
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften Leben und
dieses Leben in
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften heißt das
Leben in engem Raum wir haben auch große
gemeinschaftsunterkünfte Ausdruck dessen
ist eine Zeltstadt in Bensheim in der
etwa 800 Menschen leben in der jede
Personengruppe also Familien jeweils nur
einen kleinen Ecke hat die durch
Bauzäune die verkleidet sind abgetrennt
ist Stockbetten und Spinte und natürlich
kann in einer solchen Zeltstadt weder
vernünftige Unterbringung für
dauererfolgen noch Integrationsarbeit
stattfinden es geht aber weiter wir sind
eine zuzugsregion hier im
Rhein-Main-Gebiet das heißt
Kindergartenplätze und Schulplätze waren
eh schon da jetzt soll in Kindergärten
und Schule Integration von Kindern
erfolgen die hier angekommen sind das
ist schlichtweg räumlich schon kaum
möglich sie hat gestern eine
Schulleiterin erzählt dass sie eine
nachmittagsbetreuungsgruppe aus dem Raum
schmeißen musste um dort eine Sprache
Intensivklasse unterzubringen aber die
Fachkräfte fehlen inzwischen auch es ist
eh den Kommunen schon kaum möglich
Kindergärten personell auszustatten weil
zu wenig Pädagogen auf dem Markt sind zu
wenig Lehrer auf dem Markt sind und nun
fehlen die Fachkräfte um die
geflüchteten zu betreuen das heißt es
fehl Raum und es fehlt das Personal und
das ist zwar für eine kurze Zeit eine
Perspektive mit der man umgehen könnte
aber wir wissen inzwischen aus 2015/2016
heraus dass das eben keine kurzfristige
Situation ist wir haben etwa 700
Menschen die im Jahr 2015 zu uns kamen
die jetzt noch die
mannschaftsunterkünften leben also jetzt
sieben Jahre später noch ein
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften leben weil
unser Wohnungsmarkt erschöpft ist und
auch viele Menschen die hierher ziehen
weil sie Arbeitsplatz finden keine
Wohnung finden und das bietet doch
riesen Herausforderungen für unsere
Gesellschaft und im Blick darauf sind
alle 60
Entschuldigung weil ich will sie
bekommen ich will sie gar nicht
unterbrechen ich würde nur gern weil der
der Fächer so breit ist an Themen den
sie gerade aufgemacht haben ein bisschen
das nacheinander abarbeiten denn das
sind natürlich alles im Einzelnen ganz
ganz wichtige Punkte lassen Sie uns doch
mal erst bei der Situation der Menschen
in Unterkünften bleiben sie haben es
geschildert dass es teilweise sehr sehr
schwierig und wir haben eine
Flüchtlingshelferin die auch noch mal
beschreibt welche Unterschiede es macht
aus welchen Strukturen die Leute kommen
die die hier nach Deutschland geflüchtet
sind
also toll hat man gesehen bei den
Vernetzungstreffen kamen einfach die
Familien bei uns rein mit den Kindern
wir haben Bastelangebot gemacht und
schnell waren über Kinder tolle Brücken
gebaut also wir haben mit den gebastelt
gespielt haben geguckt dass sie Kleider
bekommen haben die Hilfsbereitschaft von
Sachspenden und auch von anderen
Organisationen es hat einfach
reibungslos geklappt also man kann sich
wirklich die Vernetzung der
Hilfsorganisation war toll von Tafel bis
kleinere Vereine gewesen Bergstraße und
Caritas und Kirchengemeinden und die
haben sich einfach uns auch sehr
geöffnet das heißt wir haben mit den
Feste gefeiert wir haben aber auch mit
denen geweint und das war gerade in dem
Zusammenhalt weil das
Familienkonstellation war für uns als
Mitarbeiter und ehrenamtlich vom
Familienzentrum auch viel einfacher
Herr Engelhardt ich Brick hier Blicke
hier mal ganz kurz in den Chat und sehe
dass es eine heiße Diskussion gibt auch
darüber was andere Länder tun was
europäische Lösungen sein könnten da
gibt es viele Stimmen die sagen wir
nehmen viele Flüchtlinge auf andere
müssten da noch viel mehr tun und unsere
Kapazitäten sind erreicht das lese ich
hier sehr oft und vielen Dank auch an
Joachim Lutz es hat mir jemand ein
Wasser gebracht bzw ich habe ein Wasser
hier es geht wieder vielen Dank ich bin
stabil Herr Engelhardt sie haben die die
Flüchtlingshelferin gerade gehört und
ich habe die Strukturen angesprochen
nicht die Strukturen aus denen die Leute
kommen sondern in denen Sie hier sind
das ist wichtig wenn man sieht vor allem
viele Ukraine kommen als Familien da
kann man andocken über die Kinder viele
andere Flüchtlinge sind Alleinreisende
junge Männer da ist es schwieriger zu
integrieren ganz offenbar und das
wiederum erstaunt ja auch ein bisschen
weil auch diese Tatsache haben wir schon
seit
2015/2016 da sind viele Männer die die
eingereist sind und wo man sagen könnte
da kann man doch eigentlich reagieren
und gucken wie man das besser hinbekommt
als man es in den Jahren bisher
hinbekommen hat
es gibt viele Integrationsangebote per
se also Integrationskurse
Sprachkurse wir haben viele
Ehrenamtliche Menschen die sich
engagieren mehr als tausenden Kreis
Bergstraße aber auch diese Angebote sind
im Augenblick am Limit das heißt die
Wartezeit auf einen Sprachkurs die
Wartezeit auf einen Integrationskurs ist
viel länger als sie sein dürfte und in
den großen Gemeinschaftsunterkunft wie
zum Beispiel der Zeltstadt ist diese
Arbeit schlichtweg nicht möglich und
wenn sie sich die
Schichtung der geflüchteten genauer
anschauen dann haben Sie nicht nur den
Unterschied zwischen Ukrainern und den
jungen Männern aus den Drittstaaten
sondern sie haben auch noch sehr
unterschiedliche Staaten aus den
Menschen kommen sie haben afghanische
ortskräfte die hier bleiben dürfen wäre
eingeladen haben weil sie in Afghanistan
für westliche Staaten gearbeitet haben
die jetzt sehr frustriert darüber sind
dass sie mit vielen anderen geflüchteten
Werkstatt leben dann haben sie dort
Menschen aus der Türkei die zum größten
Teil kein Bleiberecht bekommen weil die
Anerkennungsquote bei Menschen aus der
Türkei sehr niedrig ist die also dort
leben und wissen dass sie eigentlich
wieder zurück müssen das ist also eine
sehr heterogene Personengruppe und das
ist eine der großen Herausforderungen
vor den wir stehen
nun wenn ich hier in den Chat Blicke
dann sehe ich oft auch dass das Thema
Rückführungen oder Abschiebungen
thematisiert wird jetzt hat ihr
Parteikollege Brandenburgs Innenminister
Michael stübken heute gesagt wir
brauchen eine
migrationsbremse das Motto muss lauten
rückführungsoffensive statt weiterer
Aufnahmeprogramme ist das Wort
migrationsbremse in diesem Zusammenhang
angebracht
also die die Wortfindung ist generell
bei diesem Thema schwierig am Ende geht
es um Menschen und selbst wenn jemand
aus wirtschaftlicher Not nach
Deutschland kommt aus rein
wirtschaftlicher Not ist das ein
nachvollziehbares Motiv es geht nun mal
auf vielen Ländern auf der Welt den
Menschen viel viel schlechter als bei
uns allerdings müssen wir uns auch
ehrlich machen wir müssen ehrlich sein
wir können nicht x-beliebig viele
Menschen ganz aufnehmen es gibt
irgendwann Grenzen und die und da
sollten uns auf die
fokussieren die tatsächlich aus
humanitären Gründen aufgenommen werden
müssen sowieso Grundgesetz das vorsieht
und das heißt diese Mischung aus Sie
müssen es ehrlich machen was wir können
und wir wollen keine Bremse bei denen
einlegen die aus humanitären Gründen
aufgenommen werden die politische
verfolgt sind oder als Kriegsgebieten
kommen führt doch tatsächlich dazu dass
man dafür sorgen muss dass die Menschen
die kein Bleiberecht haben dass sie
tatsächlich auch nicht dauerhaft hier
bleiben
da gibt es zwei Mittel das eine ist dass
schnellere rückführen das halte ich auch
für wichtig auch dass es viel schneller
passiert als bisher das dauert alles
viel zu lange oder in den meisten Fällen
wird es gar nicht gemacht selbst wenn
Asylrecht abgelehnt wurde bleiben die
Menschen meist hier und das zweite ist
man sollte an den Grenzen bereits viel
besser kontrollieren wen man rein lässt
also am besten nur die Menschen am Ende
zu den Kommunen bringen die tatsächlich
eine große Chance auf Bleiberecht haben
und immer die Menschen aus der Türkei
vor dem Erdbeben zumindest der
Sicherheit seine neue Situation weniger
als 30% haben ein Kind Bleibeperspektive
und trotzdem kommen sie erstmal hier an
und sind dann über teilweise ja Jahre in
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften vor Ort
sagt der Landrat Christian Engelhardt
vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns in der
Sendung waren und auch noch mit
Lösungsvorschlägen oder
problemlösungsansätzen sich in die
Sendung mit eingebracht haben vielen
Dank Herr Engelhardt und wir blicken auf
die Zahlen die diesem ganzen zugrunde
liegen wie viele Menschen stellen
überhaupt in Deutschland Asylanträge wie
viele Flüchtlinge gibt es im Romberg
fast zusammen
im vergangenen Jahr wurden in
Deutschland mehr als
244.000 Asylanträge gestellt das ist ein
Anstieg um fast 28 % gegenüber 2021 die
größten Gruppen unter den Antragstellern
kamen aus Syrien Afghanistan und der
Türkei insgesamt aber lag die Zahl der
Asylanträge weit unter dem bisherigen
Höchstwert von 2016 damals waren es über
755.000 außerdem suchen Menschen aus der
Ukraine vor dem kriegsschutz in
Deutschland
2022 registrierten die Behörden und eine
Million geflüchtete
wir haben einen Migrationsforscher in
die Sendung eingeladen der sich schon
lange mit diesem Thema beschäftigt
Gerald Knaus ist Gründungsdirektor der
Denkfabrik Europeans thebility
Initiative ese schön dass Sie da sind
Herr Knaus können Sie uns mal einordnen
aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht diese
Zahlen viele haben das Gefühl die
Situation ist schlimmer als
2015/2016 alleine dadurch dass wir auch
mehr geflüchtete aus der Ukraine Ukraine
haben können Sie das ein bisschen
einordnen
ja das kann ich gerne guten Abend also
eines steht schon jetzt fest dass letzte
Jahr war ein historisches Jahr was die
Zahl der
Flüchtlinge betrifft die in Deutschland
Schutz bekommen haben es haben noch nie
in einem Jahr seit der Gründung der
Bundesrepublik seit den späten 40er
Jahren so viele Menschen in Deutschland
Schutz erhalten wie 2022 und das erklärt
den Großteil der
Herausforderung vor der die Kommunen die
Landwirte die Bürgermeisterin entstehen
über 1,1 Millionen Menschen haben Schutz
erhalten das gab es noch nie aber man
muss dazu sagen auch in der Europäischen
Union gab es noch nie so viele
Flüchtlinge wie im letzten Jahr und das
ist zu einem Großteil über 80% eine
Folge des Angriffs Russlands in der
Ukraine
wenn sie sich dann vor diesem
Hintergrund den Gipfel heute anschauen
wie kommentieren Sie die Ergebnisse
also ich glaube tatsächlich was auch
vorhin schon gesagt würde wir müssen uns
ehrlich machen man muss sehr klar sagen
was hier passiert also erstens wir haben
einen Angriffskrieg der in einem der
bevölkerungsreichsten Staaten Europas
fast ein Drittel der Bevölkerung 12
Millionen Menschen in nur einem Jahr
vertrieben hat viele sind in der Ukraine
geblieben die sind noch nicht gekommen
und sie wollen auch nicht fliehen aber
das Ziel der russischen Politik ist dass
in diesem Jahr noch weitere Millionen
nicht in der Ukraine leben können
5 Millionen haben in der EU einen
temporären schutzantrag gestellt und was
wir machen müssen ist ganz klar sagen
diese Krise darauf war niemand
vorbereitet und man muss jetzt zu den
Mitteln greifen in einer historischen
Krise auch historisch zu reagieren man
muss flexibler sein bei dem bei
praktischen Dingen wie bei den Kitas man
muss das Geld in die Hand nehmen und
diese Probleme zu lösen und man muss auf
europäischer Ebene viel stärker darauf
drängen dass auch andere Länder große
Flächenstaaten wie Frankreich Spanien
oder Italien einen auch nur halbwegs
adäquaten Anteil und Ukrainerinnen auch
aufnehmen denn das ist derzeit nicht der
Fall nun sehen wir an diesem Tag heute
dass die historische Antwort von Nancy
fazer ein Dashboard ist
ja das das kann es nicht sein ich warne
auch vor falschen Erwartungen
manche der Diskussionen die in den
letzten Tagen geführt wurden ich gebe
nur ein Beispiel
Abschiebungen es ist extrem wichtig dass
Abschiebungen ausreisepflichtiger vor
allem Straftäter und Gefährder aus
vielen Gründen besser funktionieren und
da da soll und muss die Bundesregierung
arbeiten aber im letzten Jahr wurden
etwa 50.000 Menschen in erster Instanz
abgelehnt 1,1 Millionen haben Asyl
bekommen also wenn alle die abgelehnt
werden und es gehen ja noch viele
Berufung abgeschoben würden dann wären
das weniger als 5% der Zahl die
Deutschland unterbringen muss und wenn
noch einmal einige hunderttausende
Ukrainerinnen kommen weil der Krieg in
der Ukraine eine Wende nimmt ungünstig
für die Ukraine dann sind auch dreimal
so viele Abschiebungen in diesem Jahr im
letzten Jahr keine wirkliche Entlastung
für die Kommunen also wir brauchen
natürlich kurzfristige Maßnahmen wir
brauchen mittelfristige Maßnahmen
migrationsabkommen damit weniger
Menschen kommen die keinen Schutz
brauchen wir brauchen Kontrolle aber
kurzfristig müssen wir uns darauf
einstellen und da ist eine der
wichtigsten Sachen auch die
Unterstützung für private Aufnahme wir
brauchen die Haushalte die in der Lage
waren die bereit waren Leute aufzunehmen
für einige Zeit die müssen vom Staat ich
glaube das würde sehr helfen noch mehr
unterstützt werden auch finanziell wie
das in Irland passiert oder auch in
Tschechien denn staatliche Unterkünfte
für all diese Menschen und weitere die
kommen könnten sind extrem schwer zu
finden
darf ich dazu direkt eine Nachfrage
stellen wir haben gesehen dass der
mediendienst Integration folgende Zahlen
liefert der sagt in Bayern und im
Saarland zum Beispiel sind die
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen zu 90% gelebt
auch Baden-Württemberg und
Sachsen-Anhalt melden dass die
Einrichtungen weitgehend ausgelastet
sind jetzt hingegen Hessen Sachsen
Schleswig-Holstein und Thüringen dagegen
melden dass nur rund die Hälfte der
Plätze belegt sei wenn das so ist dann
brauche ich doch eigentlich keine
Privathaushalte sondern dann muss ich
doch nur schauen wie ich die Menschen
besser verteilen kann
ja natürlich man muss alles nützen was
geht aber wenn ich ihn über die Grenze
Blicke in die Nachbarstaaten und
Deutschland ist ja und das ist
vielleicht auch es keine Beruhigung aber
es ist so wichtig als Kontext ist ja
nicht unter den acht Ländern in Europa
die pro Kopf die größte Zahl aufgenommen
haben Tschechien Polen die baltischen
Staaten die Slowakei haben ja pro Kopf
noch mehr Menschen aufgenommen Polen und
Tschechien 4% der Bevölkerung in
Deutschland waren es 1,2% der
Bevölkerung Ukrainer die einen Antrag
gestellt haben wie haben die das
geschafft wie schaffen die das die sind
nicht reicher als Deutschland die sind
nicht besser organisiert die schaffen
das durch private Unterkunft und auch
die haben natürlich Probleme aber es ist
klar ich rede jetzt auch von dem was wir
erwarten müssen die Krise ist ja nicht
vorbei wenn wir jetzt zurückblicken
könnten und sagen was ist bis jetzt
passiert ist dass das eine aber der
Krieg läuft ja weiter und es ist ja
nicht unrealistisch dass noch weitere
100.000 kommen könnten und ja und aus
meiner wirklich alles nützen die die
staatlichen Kapazitäten wo sie frei sind
und die private Aufnahmebereitschaft und
natürlich die europäische Dimension die
wurde bei dem Gipfel letzte Woche in
Brüssel total ignoriert da hat man
überhaupt nicht über die Ukraine
gesprochen
wenn ich hier in die Chats gucke dann
sehe ich dass es viele Forderungen gibt
zum Beispiel das Asylrecht zu ändern und
vor allem ist der Tenor eher wir
schaffen das nicht wir können nicht noch
mehr Menschen auflehnen aufnehmen das
ist also würde ich sagen dass die
Mehrheit der Kommentare hier in den
Chats und das bringt mich noch mal zu
der Frage nach den Abschiebungen auch
weil die wie gesagt auch ganz oft hier
gestellt wird Thomas gerade jetzt fragt
Frage an Herrn Knaus warum nimmt man
Leute auf bei denen man schon bei der
Aufnahme weiß man kann sie nicht
abschieben
naja da muss man unterscheiden es gibt
Leute die kann man nicht abschieben weil
sie Schutz bekommen weil sie nach
deutschem und europäischen Recht
anerkannt werden wie fast alles Syrer
die kommen und wie alle Afghanen von den
100.000 Menschen die im letzten Jahr
Schutz bekamen waren wenn ich mich recht
erinnere über 70.000 Syrer und Afghanen
dann gibt es Menschen die man nicht
abschieben kann weil wir mit den Staaten
keine Beziehungen haben Russland in
diesem Moment ich glaube auch in Iran wo
jetzt deine unglaubliche Repression
stattfindet
es ist auch mit Eritrea praktisch
unmöglich also es gibt auch Staaten wo
das nicht geht aber es stimmt natürlich
jede Anstrengung kann helfen es ist
absurd wenn Leute aus der Türkei die
nicht verfolgt werden es gibt Verfolgung
aber viele die kommen werden nicht
verfolgt dass die einen Asylantrag
stellen das kann man nur reduzieren
indem man sehr schnell Verfahren macht
und dann einen Partner hat ein Land hat
in dem Fall die Türkei die dann sagt ja
wir nehmen die Leute auch schnell zurück
auch Georgier auch Moldawien das sind
Länder mit großen wirtschaftlichen
Problemen aber die sollen nicht ins
Asylsystem kommen weil die werden nicht
verfolgt das gleiche gilt für die
meisten Menschen aus Nordafrika Tunesien
und andere nur wenn wir dann
zurückschauen auf die Zahlen in
Deutschland die aller allermeisten die
heute von den Zahlen 2022 die die
Herausforderung darstellen sind
Ukrainerinnen ihre Kinder Afghanen Syrer
also Menschen bei denen Abschiebung
deswegen nicht in Frage kommen weil sie
Schutz erhalten
dann lassen Sie uns noch mal über den
Punkt der Integration sprechen und da
hat in dieser Woche der grüne Landrat
Jens Marco Scherf aus Bayern bei Markus
Lanz der Ihnen ja auch wohl bekannt ist
einen Satz rausgehauen der auf Social
Media unter anderem für viel Aufregung
gesorgt hat hören wir mal rein
wenn ich mir anschaue unter der Prämisse
des Migration auch in meinem Landkreis
im Großen und Ganzen eine
Erfolgsgeschichte ist aber wenn ich in
meine Kindergärten schaue in die Schulen
in die normale Interaktion dann dann
haben wir ein Problem damit dass wir
Verhaltensweisen haben die finde ich mit
dem p-wort eigentlich noch verniedlichen
umschrieben die die Frauen nicht ernst
nehmen muss konkret zu machen dass
LehrerInnen nicht ernst genommen werden
von Vätern das Mütter nicht alleine zu
elternsprechtabenden kommen dürfen das
junge Frauen Mädchen in der Berufsschule
Angst davor haben wenn sie sich im
Unterricht äußern und den Integration
gelingen soll dann müssen wir auch den
Mut haben Missstände ganz offen
anzusprechen ohne dass wir dann die
Familie werden dass wir damit alle
verunglimpfen wollen aber wir müssen
über die Missstände sprechen können um
auch was dagegen unternehmen zu können
ja dann lassen Sie uns das p-wort
rauslassen und die Emotionen auch und
über die Fakten sprechen wie steht es
denn um die Integration
ich glaube es ist wichtig die Themen
schon zu trennen denn bei der Probleme
bei der Integration da geht es auch
darum dass es Menschen gibt die
vielleicht sogar in Deutschland geboren
sind oder die schon sehr lange hier sind
die nicht erst als Flüchtlingen jüngster
Zeit gekommen sind heute Abend bei
Markus Lanz gibt es eine Diskussion da
ist die Integrationsbeauftragte aus
Neukölln dabei ich war da auch dabei
also das ist eine Diskussion über
Probleme die nicht im letzten Jahr
entstanden sind was natürlich zutrifft
ist wenn es nicht gelingt die die Jetzt
ankommen
mit Integrationskursen Sprachkursen und
auch in den Kindergärten abzuholen daran
verschaffen sich diese Probleme aber
diese Probleme die werden nicht
geschaffen durch die Entwicklungen im
letzten Jahr und vielleicht eine Zahl
noch im ganzen letzten Jahr ist die
gesamte irreguläre Migration über das
gesamte Mittelmeer also von Spanien bis
Griechenland und Zypern aus der Türkei
aus AFG daran aus Syrien und aus Afrika
insgesamt waren es 160.000 die
irreguläre gekommen sind die
allermeisten nach Italien das waren so
viele wie im Anfang März letzten Jahres
an einem Tag aus der Ukraine in die EU
gekommen sind das ist wir haben derzeit
gar keine gewaltigen Zustrom von
außerhalb der EU was wir allerdings
haben ist dass wir in der EU-Staaten
haben die die Menschenrechte und das
Asylrecht ausgesetzt haben de facto und
jetzt kommen die die einen Asylantrag
stellen
bevorzugt in eine kleine Gruppe von
Staaten die kommen dann nach Österreich
in die Schweiz nach Deutschland nach
Frankreich und andere Länder Kroatien
hatte im letzten Jahr 20 Menschen Asyl
gewehrt das ist vier pro Million
Einwohner in Ungarn gibt es überhaupt
keine Asylanträge de facto das ist wir
haben auch ein Problem der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit in den EU-Staaten
die die Standards nicht mehr
respektieren und damit auf Kosten
anderer die die in die EU kommen und es
sind wie gesagt nicht ungewöhnlich viele
die kommen dann und konzentrieren sich
in Ländern wo auch noch eine große Zahl
von Ukrainern sind
Herr Knaus eine Frage noch zum Schluss
es gibt ja jetzt einen
sonderbevollmächtigten für
migrationsabkommen was erwarten sie von
ihm
also ich glaube das ist ein extrem
positiver Schritt der allerdings keine
Wunder vollbringen kann zwei Dinge sind
realistisch zu erwarten das erste und
das hat Joachim Nordrhein-Westfalen
schon gemacht als stellvertretender
Ministerpräsident sich konzentrieren
systematisch daran arbeiten alle
Straftäter und Gefährder die man
abschieben kann
abzuschieben und darüber mit den Ländern
den Herkunftsländern zu sprechen
gleichzeitig auch migrationsabkommen
abzuschließen um zukünftige irreguläre
Migration
in die EU und nach Deutschland zu
reduzieren das geht nicht schnell aber
der Ansatz ist der richtige der steht
auch im Koalitionsvertrag es ist
allerdings das hat natürlich auch mit
der Ukraine Krise zu tun ein Jahr
vergangen bevor diese extrem wichtige
Ernennung passierte das Problem ist
kurzfristig wird das die Kommune nicht
entlasten aber wenn es so läuft wie im
Koalitionsvertrag sehen wenn alle
Regierungsmitglieder und Minister und
Ministerinnen den sonderbevollmächtigten
unterstützen dann kann es mittelfristig
zu einer viel besseren Situation führen
Gesundheit Herr Knauß Gesundheit
alles Gute und vielen Dank dass Sie im
Stream dabei waren denn damit sind wir
auch schon passend zum Ende der Sendung
angelangt am Ende der Sendung angelangt
vielen Dank Herr Knaus und vielen Dank
an euch dass ihr so fleißig mit
diskutiert und auch Fragen gestellt habt
danke schön bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss